moi je m'en fous en revanche j'aime bien
savoir la shoah des choses donc j'ai
enquêté sur toi le marchand fausse elle
n'est pas très aimable avec le personnel
avec les salariés elle fait fausse
gentil tout cas un côté très
condescendant du coup dans cette
émission avec les agriculteurs qu'elle
en fasse et j'arrive si bien payé j'ai
plein de fric je vienne la ville
c'est ce que je rentre en personne ne
voit qu'elle se fout de leur gueule aux
goûts mais alors si vous avez un petit
peu les tomates ça se voit quelque peu
l'organisation jamais elle sera tirée
par un de ces garçons là ça se voit
quand je tourne brûle ses dents saines
en attendant qu'elles maîtrisent mal
elle n'est pas journaliste politique
elle ne s'est pas rendu compte de ce à
quoi le jouet les victimes du buzz
qu'elle a voulu faire l armée hier
qu'elle a voulu prendre
on va là alors non merci d'abord il y
avait à charge
karine rituel ouais c'est karine vous
êtes d'accord vous regardez beaucoup
touche pas à mon poste
et à chaque fois et vous en met plein la
gueule ce soit vous avez quelque chose à
lui dire
karine cet homme en fait le ton a changé
à partir d'une émission de tpm paix où
j'étais invité et je me suis métier ce
qui se passe je suis là et en fait lors
de cette émission c'était le jour où on
avait annoncé que claire chazal quitté
tf1 est question parmi tant d'autres
cyril me dit est ce que tf1 a le droit
de vivre est claire chazal sera bon bah
oui c'est une chaîne privée qui fait
quand même ce qu'elle veut avec ses
journalistes
et voilà ils vont apprendre à développer
sur ce truc là mais c'était mon opinion
à partir de ce moment là je suis l'objet
de ta détestation tu inventes des choses
sur moi parce que si on pose la question
année des déserts et culteurs il serait
quand même comment répondre mais bon
voilà tu as inventé plein de trucs
qu'importe a le droit de ne pas aimer ce
que je fais ta laura désir ce que tu
veux contre moi mais tu appelleras
d'inventer des choses donc je me suis
dit bon je vais pas une réponse ou tout
ça ça glisse ainsi on a peur des de ce
genre de remarque on arrête ce métier
tout de suite on arrête twitter on
arrête tout et on
sourire donc moi je m'en fous en
revanche j'aime bien savoir la shoah des
choses donc j'ai enquêté sur toi
apparemment apparemment vous allez donc
intégré milieu de la pègre
quand on déteste à ce point une personne
ça veut dire que j'ai touché ton coeur
ça veut dire que quelque chose chez moi
à fait que ça t'a ébranlé avec un et
voilà le mercy et bien sûr en un mot et
est donc je me suis je me suis renseigné
auprès de toi et il ya quelque chose qui
revient toujours quand tu perds quand tu
parles de claire chazal s'est tue dix
jours elle est comme ma mère c'est
manquent pas ouais non ouais j'aime
beaucoup
tu dis âgées pas je te jure je les
entends dire mais moi pour moi que comme
ma mère voilà et je sais que tu as perdu
ta mère et je pense que tu as fait un
transfert
on s'en est parlé une fois c'est bien en
fait on s'en est parlé à une semaine
dans une fête chez les devoirs et je
t'ai dit voilà qu'est ce qui se passe
comme tu avais un petit peu bu et moi
aussi
la plèbe la parole s'est délié est a
reconnu qu'effectivement ne supportait
pas que j'ai pu dire du mal mais j'ai
pas dit du mal de cars chazal j'ai le
droit de dire que dans ce métier on a
droit partir moi même je suis un chien
je suis un objet de deux tu vois de
publicité quelque part et le jour je
marcherai plus on me [ __ ] à dehors
j'en ai conscience donc c'est valable
pour tout le monde et claire chazal elle
a pris la place de quelqu'un ça n'était
pas contre elle je suis d'accord avec ce
système c'est ça qui nous fait bien
vivre c'est aussi parce qu'on gagne
beaucoup d'argent qu'on peut partir d'un
jour à l'autre
toi tu t'es tu t'es focaliser sûrement à
cause de ça et depuis je suis un objet
d'aider des bdd à détestation c'est vrai
ou c'est faux
mathieu c'est vrai voilà non mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai que ce jour
là
la phrase exacte qui m'avait blessé
c'est comment je suis très ami avec
claire chazal elle est s'est fait virer
d'une manière vraiment dégueulasse par
tf1 il s'est fait marcher dessus par des
angles comme morandini ou d'autres qui
le détestaient c'est une femme qui a un
certain âge et qui ne méritait pas ça
elle a été très triste très touché par
tout ça et qu'on parte avec avec 2000
euros ou avec des millions d'euros il
n'empêche qu'on peut être malheureux et
mal de vivre et c'est vrai que ce jour
là vous avez dit tu as tué dit à
l'antenne ce jour là est ce que dit à
plein de gens qui sont virés tous les
jours on n'en fait pas tout un drame et
moi
je savais que la chose elle était très
touché par tout ça on disait beaucoup de
même beaucoup de bêtises sur elle des
chaleurs incroyable et ce jour là
effectivement c'est mon ami toi tu as
des amis et je le sais que tu défends
moi c'est mon ami je l' ai défendu mais
moi quand je défends quelqu'un c'est pas
pour autant que je vais attaquer ou
inventer sur la personne qui les aident
je reconnais qu après j'en ai fait une
affaire un peu personnel c'est vrai
est-ce que tu d'accord c'est une
question d' immaturité quelque part
affective je reconnais qu après sa
défaite à faire un peu personnel
cette partie là je reconnais et est ce
que tu crois pas que tu aurais tout à
gagner de parler plus avec ton coeur
plutôt que de faire des fixettes sur des
gens et de dire ben moi cette personne
qu'on a dit ça elle m'a blessée parce
que voilà tout ce que tu nous dis là et
je pense que tu serais plus ou moins qui
passera moins pour un con je passe pour
un con il va falloir falloir qu'ils
sachent un moment c'est vrai trois
secondes ce qui est vrai c'est que il ya
une semaine il ya une semaine je vais un
anniversaire et je savais pas du tout et
j'arrive à minuit et tout d'un coup on
n'était pas nombreux à 20,25 dans le
noir off
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
golding unibody tombe sur karine et du
coup c'est vrai qu'on s'est parlé
c'est vrai qu'on sait des choses plutôt
intime et plus de chance et que karine
mais maintenant eh ben on est de dire et
j'aimerais te les dire à l'antenne comme
ça les gens le verront aussi et même la
conclusion ça a été et du coup tu m'as
dit on part dans quelques jours ce
qu'est ce que tu veux venir avec nous
c'est vrai ou pas oui c'est vrai
partouche pas je peux pas encore mais
peut-être fin mars en moins d'un vrai
qu'avec sa violence mais moi je lis and
on ne le dit pas alors que je fais ici
alors est un truc pas dire par là c'est
parce que c'est vrai qu'à km qui j'en ai
42 poteau 1-2 d'un ami gay parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'amis gays voilà donc
avec qui vous portent avec qui vous
jouez pas avec des amis sériba voiture
mais le camp de la vérité vérité moi
lâche maintenant alors attends je finis
[Rires]
ça va être une limonade
alors je préfère
d'accord juste pour fournir oui moi je
pense que quand on parle avec son coeur
et franchement je le fais aussi dans mes
émissions je le fais dans ma vie on a
tout à gagner et il faut dire ce qui
nous peine et ça nous évite de faire des
deux braqué comme ça qu'on fera des gens
maintenant moi je t'en veux pas c'est le
jeu de la télévision mais mais parfois
tu une caricature de toi même et je
crois que ce serait mieux si tu étais
dans dans le temps ta vérité on allumait
soit freinage est très honnête mais ce
serait un très bon match
est-ce que tu as un truc à dire avec ton
coeur à karine est ce que ce que là je
crois qu'on tient fort mahon tient une
forme à ce que tu feras tu as dix
secondes pour prendre l'addition est ce
que tu as envie de prendre
karine dans tes bras afin de faire un
gros câlin est-ce que je peux le dire en
tout cas ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est
que je reconnais que j'ai dit des choses
que je ne pensais pas forcément ce que
je pense et je tue les dix autres soirs
c'est que je crois que tu es une des
milliards animatrice tu as la foi le
physique l'intelligence le talent
antenne vraie personnalité et c'est vrai
qu'ensuite j'ai tapé beaucoup parce que
parce que tu m'avais fait mal et que du
coup lui quand j'aime les gens je les
défends kit est parfois un peu de
mauvaise foi ce que j'ai été et sur
cette partie là je m'en excuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]